When I'm playing Assassin's Creed or Call
of Duty, my brain is totally absorbed in this
virtual environment.
But what happens to my brain when I come out
of it?
Is it different?
This WEEK, we humans will spend 3 billion
hours playing video games; 1.2 billion people
play regularly...
99 percent of boys and 94 percent of girls
under 18 lock their eyeballs on a video game
quote "regularly" according to game designer
and author Jane McGonigal.
That's an incredible amount of time living
in what amounts to an alternate reality for
the brain.
A study from the Proceedings of the Royal
Society B that came out last December (I think
it just came out in the journal - maybe the
study was conducted last December?) , looked
at the brains of gamers while playing and
offer another alleged turn in the thumbscrews
of action games…
Their study found that video game players
have a less robust striatum nucleus -- the
part of the brain that constructs an internal
representation of the outside world.
Essentially, games aren't helping people learn
to map the real world, at least according
to this study.
Action gamers are using something called "response
learning" instead of the more advanced "place
learning."
To simplify, imagine you're trying to get
to a familiar place like a friend's house
or your favorite restaurant: "response learning"
is when your brain creates a map using landmarks;
but "place learning" is an advanced internal
map so you know to turn based on distance
and direction -- it's the difference between
associating lots of little bits of information
… "I have to turn when I see the gas station"
as opposed to combining that information into
an understanding of the external world.
These researchers think the action video game
players are under-developing their striatum
to such a degree that it might affect them
throughout their lives; they may even develop
a neurological disorder!
Some news outlets have called this a risk
of Alzheimers, but that's a pretty damn big
jump.
Here’s the thing: for every study of games
negatively affecting our brains there are
plenty of studies saying the opposite.
A study in July of last year in Molecular
Psychiatry put gamers into magnetic resonance
imagers to reveal how grey matter was developing
in their cabezas.
They found a correlation in the size of the
entorhinal cortex, and left occipital cortex/inferior
parietal lobes related to their 'joystick
years' or the amount of time they played certain
video games.
According to their results, people who played
more logic, puzzle, and platform games had
a larger entorhinal cortex, but action-based
role-playing games had a smaller one.
The entorhinal cortex works with the hippocampus
to create memories and maps of your life -- so
you know when and where something happened
as well as how it fits in with what happened
the day before, or last time you met that
person.
Another study in that journal from February
of the same year found similar results using
games like Commander Keen and Super Mario
64.
Science is saying, platformers and logic games
are great for the entorhinal cortex, even
while action-based games aren't.
That being said, however, the hippocampus
and grey matter in ALL video game players
had added plasticity overall!
Plasticity is the ability for the brain to
adapt and change neural pathways.
More plasticity is better!
And it's not just the plasticity, a study
done with chimpanzees published in Science
News last month assessed how chimps brains
responded to video games.
After teaching them to play a cooperative
game, the researchers found cells in the chimp's
brains predicted what the next move of the
OTHER chimp 79.4 percent of the time!
These chimps understood what was going on
in the brains of their co-op players.
We KNOW video games change how our brain works,
but whether that's a good or bad thing seems
to change as new research comes out…
We cover this research all the time.
For instance, do videogames make you more
aggressive?
Joe Bereta explores that idea in this episode